Let's go to our caller from the two oh two
area code.
Who's calling today from two zero two?
Yeah, that's, yeah.
Uh, Yo, what's up David?
Uh, no.
From this one forward, I guess if you recognize
this number you can just call me Tommy.
Tommy.
Okay.
We'll enter that into our system.
Mm.
Uh, I just want to say I love, I guess I discuss
and one or two things, uh, first thing would
be like, uh, how I avoided that whole right-wing
echo chamber as you call it for the youtube
space.
Yup.
Yeah.
And if maybe we got more time, I want to talk
about squat, but our right wing echo chamber
thing.
Um, I'm, I'm a black.
All right.
I'm from DC.
Okay.
So that's typically speaking by default.
I, it's very less leaning, you know, that's
kind of the whole environment here.
Um, but my interest, my main interest is video
games.
Basically.
So much of video games are kind of like influenced
my interest going forward.
Like, uh, uh, my taste in film, I taste in
music and so forth.
Uh, but then, uh, basically if we can start
seeing certain types of commentators about
video games online here and there, and I have
them tend to get political from time to, uh,
I think what one of the ones that kind of
resonated or Kinda like, like a, I really
started liking becoming a fan of was this
dude named razor for this?
You familiar with him?
No, no, no, not at all.
Okay.
Um, so what happened was basically I was eating,
here's a lot of this, uh, the comments and
he paid a lot of funny stuff, make a lot of
funny videos are talking Matt.
It's like kind of an edge lord kind of talking
about, it's about all types of games and culture
and movies and such.
Then you also start getting political rhetoric
and basically speaking, eventually I realized,
Oh, this guy's a far right, libertarian type
do.
Um, even I'll start pulling out support for
Trump.
Um, and I kind of started buying some of his
arguments as well.
And even with saying like, go check out Steve.
Stefan Molyneux, uh, and some people like
to call it.
Um, and honestly I was just, I'm like, I don't
have the time to do all this other stuff cause
this guy has just all politics and everything.
Cause this is before I got my political awakening
I guess you could say and happened was this
is how I got about to look away because there
was this other guy, uh, I was just starting
to con no, no actually no.
What happened was I've had,
yeah, what a while I'm confused.
So I was falling to do Ray's assistant.
Then eventually he ended up pointed out having
Ian up pointed out the exit slip is do name
of Utec was talking about like playstation
next boxes and their launch.
And then I started watching his stuff.
They used to also end up having like these
with each other and later down the line they
squashed it.
They doing their own thing now.
So don't buy, I try to bring up old mess.
But Review Tech also ended up pointing out
how he was a fan of Kyle Kalinsky.
And eventually I was like, okay, check this
out.
But again, it's like Steven Molyneux was like,
I'm not really into political stuff like this
or so forth.
I'm like, I'm hearing this guy stuff and I'm
hearing this guy stuff, but I'm just not really
tweeting.
He's at gates but then raise raises fist guy
too with the bait was Kyle Kalinsky that was
monitored by a, I think it was like TJ Kirk,
atheist and everything and so I'll watch that
and I was like, I finally found like some
type of political philosophy that I can abide
with because Kyle was just saying stuff that
I was like, this makes sense to me.
Like straight up because I'm accepting of
the criticisms that [inaudible] was saying
about like of left and like a lot of the establishment
circles, but there's clearly a lot of crap.
You can also flow in at the right.
Okay.
Now tell me, let me ask you this.
How old a guy are you?
Oh, well right now I'm 26
yeah, right now I met [inaudible].
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But this happened a while back and everything.
Got It.
I think it's a congratulations on avoiding
the right way.
An Echo chamber or at least getting out of
it before you were, you were fully pulled
in and a hope it's not too hot down there
in Washington DC.
And I hope to hear from you again.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, great.
Tommy, take care to hit Tommy from DC.
Shot out of a cannon today.